Grand-père, où sommes-nous, tu dois
découvrir les mystères du monde, la
magie est tout autour de nous, rien de tel ne se
rassemble autour de moi, je t'apporte une créature dont on
parle seulement dans les mythes et les légendes,
elle ne peut pas être
silencieuse, wow,
aucune bouteille n'en a vu depuis des siècles,
ils pourraient  sois mignon salut
Gizmo je m'appelle Sam mais cette espèce est
extrêmement dangereuse
est-ce vrai
à quel point cela peut-il être dangereux
personne d'autre n'a de soucis
tu dois le ramener chez lui
je viens avec toi
merveilleux nous avons une carte que personne ne
comprend sauf un  écureuil magique
qui parle du charabia
Je suppose que cela ne signifie pas que
tout va bien
[Applaudissements]
allez chercher ces femmes-mogwives, allez les chercher Sam
sera à moi,
vous savez Kung Fu
[Musique]